pub
[Musique]
oh
des mots
[Musique]
en
[Applaudissements]
c'est bonjour des papiers s'il vous
plaît
jean macé
bon elle hésite
où est passé
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur pour tr carte
d'identité s'il vous plaît
vous avez quelque chose à déclarer en
rien du tout dans nos amis a dit merci
sarko cieux vous avez votre avenir
complètement à plat de sa vie entre la
changer mais thibault a coûté on va vous
aider à la mjc le buzz
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
eh bien ne comptez pas sur moi je suis
lié par le secret professionnel
je ne vous donnerai aucun renseignement
monsieur l'inspecteur non mais écoutez
je suis pas inspecteur de police - sas
aux toxicomanes ça me concerne pas je
suis inspecteur principal de la
direction des enquêtes douanières et
elle a un rôle bien précis la direction
des enquêtes douanières
c'est la répression la prévention
d'acteurs couper la route aux
trafiquants de drogue avant qu'il ne
s'installe chez nous aux revendeurs
saleté découvrir leurs bases pour les
démanteler
[Musique]
au delà de la fin d'article autres pour
signer quatre temps notre vie pastorale
[Musique]
ok
l'autre marque disney là haut
mein gott réaction des bras s'agiter un
certain gaston curé rpt en français il
transportait de l'héroïne dit mathieu
pour vérifier rapidement
il est peut être connu dès vos services
je me renseigne immédiatement je vous
rappelle werner merci mathieu mais elle
fait vite s'il vous plaît
d'accord werner pluriel oui vers noël
c'est un gros coup faut que j'aille
officier si tout ce que tu peux être
gentil avec ce dernier la gare de
strasbourg ont laissé passer un client
qui s'est fait choper accueil et ça ça
s'appelle une dette
moi mes dettes gp toujours petite mer
pour moi être un rendez vous drague avec
sa collaboratrice pendant le service
parents monsieur l'inspecteur principal
mais je reste modestement aux ordres de
son supérieur hiérarchique
si l'heureux imbéciles peut-être mais
heureux sur mon peuple attend de son
caractère avant ce n'était pas un cadeau
mais depuis qu'il a arrêté de fumer je
vais te dis en moi j'en ai le bol
pire et gustav
ouais ouais ouais
gustave
non pas de gaston gustave du staff pirée
avec et accent aigu rivèrenert ceux du
petit gibier a été interpellé une fois
en soixante dix à marseille il a purgé
sa peine n'était pas aux clients bon on
verra gpat à paris oui pourquoi
mp si vous deviez vous le dire routier
de fonds il faut que je vous vois de
toute urgence
j'ai trouvé quelque chose qui peut nous
intéresser tous les deux mathieu je
prends le prochain avion envoyé ma
voiture à orly merci
[Musique]
si vous voulez me suivre
bonjour muriel hobo jean bernège vous
avez fait vous voyez si mathieu oui vous
attend alors que ce qui se passe werner
je crois tu n'iras ne pas en piste mais
il faut aller vite mathieu monde
celui-ci des transports de deux kilos et
demi d'héroïne pure dans la roue de sa
voiture mais c'est pas mal ça deux kilos
et demi à 800 grammes
ça allait chercher dans les 2 millions
de francs lui oh oui sa salade rose
qu'il ya n'est ce pas voilà c'est que
j'ai trouvé sur lui une ha de la
provence
avec un matelas souligné avec une flèche
et une croix oui je vois sans rendez
vous ça ou un contact
en tout cas c'est tous ces corps n'a je
vous montrais mon buste aspirer à moi et
voilà mon gustave pirée et accentue l
vallamand castor pirée été acclamé
miaule une carte d'identité maquiller
c'est très beau ça et ça c'est pas bon
interpellé le 7 11 1970 à marseille à
bord du pilote numéro 712 1243 pour
trafic de stupéfiants et qu'elle soit et
rod 200 kg de cannabis deux ans de
prison
fushia la tonne est en sommeil depuis
jusqu'à ces amateurs pour l'éternité et
cher même pour un petit truand allons
voir ce qu'il veut de son bateau
ah tiens le vla son bateau
voilà
elliott qui régule stamm interpellé à
bord le 7 11 1970 voir fiche torquemada
numéro 823 1958 c'est bizarre parce que
ça veut dire torquemada lyon
mais c'est le même bateau il a seulement
changé de nom il s'appelle le torquemada
il été racheté il ya trois ans à un
armateur d'ismir mais c'est là si on
prend le show des trafics
c'est excellent nom l'armateur à l'air
propre mais il a conservé l'officier en
second du pilote une canne à votre croix
c'est une bastide perdu au milieu de la
garrigue et la flèche le chemin qui y
conduit
oui c'est pas loin de la mer est pas
moins autoroute elle rennes 3 idéal pour
l'héroïne arrivera en france sous forme
de morphine et sera traité dans cette
bastide comme au bon temps de la french
connection
c'est une hypothèse une hypothèse
suffisantes donc tu vérifies le
torquemada toqué alors port d'attache
situation actuelle derniers déplacements
et cargaisons transportées et l'âge du
capitaine
on s'habitue tu veux voir le patron oui
voilà c'est embêtant c'est du gros
gibier sur marseille / gens vont
redescendre sur marseille
aulas mon pauvre vieux tu sais qui et
l'ip et là bas oui wallon et tu va
empiéter sur son terrain de chasse
français
c'est vrai qu'il est susceptible comme
une jeune fille wallon c'est pour ça que
j'avais besoin de la bénédiction du
colonel et bien tant pis je m'en
passerais procédure exceptionnelle
écoute dit j'ai horreur te voit foncer
comme ça l'aveuglette mais qu'est ce qui
te prouve que la bastide est un
laboratoire clandestin
puis il n'y a pas de laboratoires
clandestins dans le midi en principe la
route du moyen orient et coupez les
caïds de la drogue ont toujours cherché
une base en europe 1 et une pareille
quantité de kemper ça prouve qu'ils ont
trouvé leur labo bon bon admettons la
bastide est un laboratoire mais les
trafiquants doivent savoir que le
pasteur n'a pas pu livrer la marchandise
lors du poids qui t'attend tu pour te
débarrasser c'est pour ça que je fais à
mes risques et périls et sans le feu
vert du patron procédure exceptionnelle
toujours le même torquemada et un
plaisancier qui fait souvent le trajet
izmir barcelone izmir
mon copieurs et eddy d'opium de morphine
regarde il se mit à izmir barcelone
torquemada pourrait très bien sans se
dérouter débarquer sa cargaison de
drogue dans le corse ou en sardaigne
sûrement oui mon petit verner on peut
très bien imaginer ça on s'en va par qui
oui je mêle torquemada sous surveillance
mais tu tâche de sifflet nous on s'en va
à toute allure
je te rapelle serait ce route 130g du
virage un vrai tube
[Musique]
d'après la casse et ce chemin là
cet espace
[Musique]
on voit pas être loin
aïe je l'a persuadé qu'il a remis à
louey mouture est en voiture on serait
pas arrivé à moto
aucune partout et se dissimule fatigue
la bastille à planquer la moto et on
attendra la nuit
[Musique]
les vernets
elle a abandonné pouvoir
alors on y va non pas vous c'est du
grabuge descendu au village vous appeler
ce numéro
mon collègue des douanes de marseille
wallon qui s'appelle est un poil et
grabuge deux c'est mieux
correct vous n'êtes pas ambitions 1 vous
non plus mathieu à evans et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sans lui
c'est ce qu'il faut ou non car elle
cisèle ses tics à l'achat
alors qu'est ce que c'était recevoir
pour la chaîne hbo a sûrement
ces jus maintenance en lice il
cinq ans à leur prix d'achat et je vais
la voir et chaud bien vite entre la
bande d'urgence au téléphone oui
j'arrive il serait bien plus ait soudain
gâchette bon vernis pour rester ici
moi je veux mettre en planque près du
garage derrière la maison d'accord merde
ok genres entre deux mais ma terre si
l'on peut dire qu'il ya eu une bavure la
frontière de la petite fronde pour des
modes d tout le matériel
moi je vais m'occuper nova leur plaque
pour la bo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
on
[Musique]
les cabinets tout comme la salle
messieurs je suis là à votre commune a
donné un café
un vite vite robin tu plais pas
marseille que toi le trafic vient c'est
heureux si elles entrent ou de la ville
la fête on arrive de voitures avec moi
procure immédiate
[Musique]
mais yu
à
à plat alors que la compagnie du si la
voiture perd le matricule et 51 01 être
l 13 gamme en général c'est pourquoi ici
pour moi j'appelle cobras de foxtrot
heures pour parler suivait la voiture au
vert attribué cet homme qui va démarrer
un rien forcé mais reçu terminée allez
vas-y
bon ben maintenant je t'amène à la
campagne parce que j'ai découvert à la
boucle en est un ça ça m'étonnerait
après si c'est vrai je tenais pas
poussins 8 février surtout par mr tout à
remonter la filière royal sur la pointe
des pieds derrière j'ai mis à regarder
ce titre le samu mais alors
de ma plaque si tu veux rester en
contact avec lui sur la route oui il est
toujours là comme un seul
will a commencé à démonter le matériel
va mieux non j'ai le plus de sécurité
très mince elle venait on ne relève pas
l 13 balles 13 reste à l'écouté terminée
écoutez collègues grâce à vous donne à
l'adresse d'un laboratoire clandestin et
toujours grâce à vous deux mais ils ont
visité deux individus qui l'ont conduit
à une ville après ton change positif
nous avons même très post comme ça je
connais cette femme c'est seulement je
connais ma région de ne pas vous pour
moi cela va encore retarder ce thème ne
servira plus jamais correct lecteurs
mais rien ne prouve ma liberté
werner excusez moi un fait rien les
mouvements ce labo est servi de relais à
un réseau à petit sachet ou l'allemagne
sera clair alors tu veux redire mes
collègues je continue à suivre la faire
à vous remercier pour votre bonne visite
et vous disent rien
[Musique]
alors oui c'est pour toi paris oui oui
marqué on fait vite je veux pas te
raconter ma vie mais je t'explique
ouais d'accord rapidement alors
torquemada est partie d'ismir depuis
quatre jours pour barcelone ouais il
faisait aujourd'hui escale à naples ana
lelas et plurielle qui parle faisait
escale à d'âpres et prato libye eh ben
je l'appelle merci salut non non mais
raccroche pas écoute peut être nerveux
vivement qu'il refuse 30 30 ans qui
parle à mathieu vous m'appelez pour les
torquemada gel et dia marquis votre
bateau il a bien fait escale en a
reparlé
si ma comme nous avons été prévenus trop
tard on n'a pas pu surveiller l'équipage
quand il est descendu à terre ça fait
deux heures qu'il a repris la mer ainsi
que pékin moi j'ai fait mettre en place
son dispositif de surveillance est celle
qui le saloon je vous fais prévenir
on a les dix mis en turquie là bas
jusqu'à barcelone
non mais non parce qu'un des signes qu
est ce qui passe par naples ce n'est pas
des trajets correct n'est ce pas un
inspecteur wallander s'est dérouté pour
livre cette drogue en france
enfin dans la mesure votre torquemada
transporte vraiment de la drogue c'est
peut-être à naples qui l'a dit oui ça
regarde le collègue italien mais pas la
dernière
sauf si la drogue était transportée par
route au labo qu'on a intérêt si au
trafic routier existait aussi régulier
en larmes des hommes remarqué se méfie
dans le bois du cerf aussi faire de
débarquement clandestin dans les petites
criques la crique le labo et l'allemagne
je tiens prêt mais qu'est ce que tu peux
être que tu toi mais l'inspecteur adore
il n'y avait pas de stupéfiants dans la
ferme
prix 1 kg de poudre ne connut et 2
d'acide acétique une hypothèse il attend
les livraisons ces jours ci leur
fourrure est pris sauve qui peut je
demande la boue et le roman terre gelée
piste je les prend en flagrant délit je
fais coffret tous capables mais ne vous
ne pouvez pas faire ça c'est du sabotage
c'est ça votre âge pourquoi le
chapeautage ballon
me collait pas mal le français et entre
nous ton action à notre action pour être
plus efficaces s'ils ont remonté la
filière jusqu'à l'allemagne déploie pas
non monsieur mathieu je ne crois pas on
remonte on laisse pourrir la police
intervient on retrouve plus rien enfin
l'inspecteur banon j'ai vraiment des
semaines des savoirs peut pas dire à
sochaux comme moi j'ai possède les
purges inapte à la fois ma région où
tout est ce un pari de laboratoire à
tester je veux pas au jeu avant comme si
on monte de voir un métier point final
oui je veux être sûre que tu as bien
compris tu as bien compris marquer il
faut absolument que du bout obtiennent
du patron qui n'accrédite officiellement
auprès de vallon le plus vite possible
alors oui c'est facile je m'étais
options les offres en direct chaque
match mais juste
[Musique]
il faudrait que je sois sur place pour
juger de toute façon l'inspecteur
principal mathieu n'est pas un superman
c'est un fonctionnaire comme nous tous
il doit se plier au règlement mais
monsieur le directeur il a la
possibilité de démonter tout un réseau
et il s'agit là d'une affaire
internationale c'est peut-être une
affaire internationale mais elle dépend
de l'inter-région de marseille wallon
est un garçon très capable mais très
susceptible
je ne veux pas de frictions
diplomatiques entre notre service est le
sien du goût envoyé un telex pour mars
et gama qui rentrait à paris
solution wallon retenue merci messieurs
alors merci à nos amis comme atari vous
faire dire ha il va être content mathieu
l2 si tu veux parce que moi j'ai pas les
nerfs faut qu'il soit réglé
mathieu et l'adn des de paris ou de
marseille c'est la même raison bien bien
bien erdik tough je fais le nécessaire
j'ai beau oui monsieur le directeur du
bourg
un nouvel élément vient de faire
rebondir la sphère la direction des
douanes de l'allemagne fédérale me fait
savoir qu'elle accrédite auprès de
l'inspecteur werner ce qui m'oblige mois
a adopté la solution mathieu est
forcément bon alors avisé marcel par
action immédiate
on remonte la filière
repli de lexicologie pas pu il te
manquer on aurait aussi manquer le
plaisir de visiter la région on est mal
de compagnie andré beirnaert correct une
structure principale moi je vais vous
dire j'ai peut-être un peu consolé
tentation de l'ispm adieu les nouvelles
de l'italie nous signons le torque evans
entre la corse et la sardaigne
et oui mais sa route normale pour aller
de mac à barcelone c'est keita prouver
qu'il a déjà été parqués ça vivre sans
manable il faut alerter tous les postes
frontière et renforcer discrètement les
contrôles routiers et ferroviaires
ok collègues oliva et messages urgents a
passé par tous les postes frontières
renforcement discret comprendre routier
et ferroviaire le père de matthieu
sinclair les talibans le torquemada a
mis le cap au nord et semble se diriger
vers la france alors vous alerter le qg
maritime et vous leur demander de garder
le torquemada sous contrôle
[Musique]
ici sa fille qu'elle est la station qui
m'appelle je vous reçois faible et
inaudible augmenter votre puissance
j'appelle saphir
ils finissent de charger d'une
camionnette grise immatriculée 4290 h j
j'alerte le dispositif en place terminé
ici à tes mains de la bastille
j'apprenne balles 13 j'appelle page 13
liguita de démarrer estibal 13
assureront le relais la prenons en
charge des mines et j'appelle erakat
j'appelle erakat ici pas lé 13 ici balle
presque la camionnette grise
immatriculée 4290 h u13 roule en
direction des cas similaires
mon
[Musique]
et
on
[Musique]
diamant de brossac de manoeuvre aux un
commando se réglaient signal torquemada
regrets en mer se rapproche de la côte
en direction de marseille le gros tube
et reçus je vais tout de suite au devant
de lui
[Musique]
affaire de diamants on s'affaire des
gamins ne recevez vous
je viens de repérer le torquemada qui
fait cap vers la pointe de polig au
regard des résultats
la diva réussi la prouesse de folie que
c'est pas là que je bâtirai mon cabanon
ouais saviez que des falaises à pic
[Musique]
et
je suis sûr qu'ils viennent de jeter à
la mer
orfi base pour la bo clandestins est
inscrite
outre l'allemagne je me demande quoi ils
vont bien pour les chercher les sacs
et
mais moi
[Musique]
pour garder ma demande je serais curieux
de savoir ce qu'ils vont faire m
[Musique]
il
on va
au travail
moi j'veux qu'on puisse pas être
vraiment flagrant délit du kop le bateau
commence par dire nous sommes pas son
corps et vous définir collègues
reste plus qu'à aller à ces dispositifs
ok
il comprend ainsi qu'au moins qu'avec le
trophée
vous allez sur rien d'autre n'a pris qu
les mille quatre cent soixante dix héros
x 83 on pourrait très bien se diriger
vers la ville ocre le sol terminent
j'appelle cobra j'appelle cobra ici
foxtrot d'autres j'ai encore ma villa
on se bat tout s'est bien passé près
très bien il y en a quatre sacs
je perds feu dit d'accord de sacs pour
des faits commis à temps faut-il pour
traiter tout ça et pour avoir de la
belle blanche faut compter cinq à six
jours ok je prends une errance
il coûte ce serait mal recon cm1 et cm2
razgrad la raison aux mêmes méthodes
il faut combien de temps cinq à six
jours maximum
ha
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
enfin depuis jamais trop tard pour
transformers en tauride matter where
it's our différence
comment allons nous vous y êtes pas le
temps il travaille pour nous
il met le temps un tas pour leurs
bateaux de faire trois voyages mais je
sais qu'on a marseille c'est pas une
raison pour tout exagéré collègues parle
et comprend 4 de saphir un joueur
souvent vous il m'a fait que les engins
à 510 ch est belle parce qu'à un oeuf
kloten 517 vient de s'arrêter devant la
villa tournesol terminée
in instructeurs sont embarqués un
bonhomme avec une jambe dans le plâtre
au en vous pensez tous les deux que je
pense non exactement et moi de même
j'appelle sa fille j'appelle saphir ici
cobra j'appelle sa fille ici cobra faire
prendre en filature l'ambulance
immatriculés au ghm 110 se dirigeant
vers l'autoroute et mettre en place le
dispositif pour la filer jusqu'à la
frontière
ici albatros ambulance immatriculés au
ghm 110 geipel oscar golf hôtel mike 110
a été aperçu sur l'autoroute mais de
valence terminée si comme il ya no
signal de chalon sur saône que le
véhicule a quitté l'otan auteurs ayant
pris la route ce 12 ans ont terminé la
place viennent de reprendre l'autoroute
a36 à montbéliard en direction de cette
fois terminée
elle attendait un tour à cana devient le
reverrai l'ambulance puis se dirige dans
le monde qu'elle terminait
m
et
[Musique]
à bien la belle
oui
[Musique]
c'est pas possible ça qu'est-ce-qui pas
possible et c'est l'accident du prophète
sur manoire m alors ne vous savez qui
c'est un des plus grands spécialistes et
la gestion de chante cigale et pour la
drogue mathieu n'a qu'à faire le trafic
dans sa clinique à toute façon
l'ambiance étant très large faut quand
même aller voir
oui bien sûr d'après la poutre yade aura
fait les politiques sont uniquement
contador
comme l'écrit sous la plume de charles
s'est vite on prend les escaliers
[Musique]
à
je
[Musique]
marseille opération terminée d'actions
immédiates sont torquemada et tournesol
doha dont la punk emmène des standings
des offrandes qui vaudra une facture
ballan marseille thaïlande imite actions
font tourner trois bureaux et des
passages est la police judiciaire a les
mains en l'air pas d'histoire
le professeur man c'est monstrueux oui
mais la monstruosité s'explique toujours
le grand blessé de guerre qui finit par
coûter la morphine google music douleur
et coûte cher en afrique et on fini par
organiser un trafic avec ses propres
malheurs
j'ai bien sûr font d'excellents vendeur
[Musique]
on
voilà
[Musique]
on
à
[Musique]